This is the insane story about how I started working
for Dean Butler,
aka Almanzo Wilder from Little House on the Prairie.
I have made a lot of content surrounding Little House.
I grew up watching them, and then
when I Learned that the cast was coming to Oklahoma,
I knew I had to try to do a collaboration with them.
And next thing I knew,
I was hanging out with the cast for a whole weekend.
There was Nelly,
there was Almanzo,
there was Miss Beetle,
and it was a wild experience.
Everyone was so kind
and made Jake and I feel like we had known them
our entire lives.
As the weekend went on,
Dean and I had several
conversations surrounding social media,
and I said, Dean,
you really need a social media presence.
There are so many people that would love to follow you
and hear all of your stories about Little House.
So he hired me on the spot,
and I became his social media manager,
and I've traveled to a few events with him so far.
We are having so much fun,
and I am just so grateful
for the opportunity to work with him.
He has such a heart to keep
the Little House legacy alive,
and I'm so grateful to have a small part in that.